well to our costs of living q a now uh
and we can bring in our contributors uh
gemma godfrey a personal finance uh
expert and dr jeevan sander an economist
from king's college uh london very good
evening to you both thanks so much for
for joining us on a fascinating topic
sadly not an upbeat one but but a very
important one uh nonetheless and we
wanted to just dive straight into it and
ask the first question which we got from
a viewer uh fraser saying will i be cut
off if i can't pay my energy bills and
and gemma maybe i'll put that one to you
in terms of what the normal course of
action is when someone uh is in a
position where they can't actually pay
the bill in the short term
well that's usually the last step that's
taken so to try and protect people
because obviously energy is is an
essential need but obviously with the
rise of the don't pay campaign you know
this is a rising risk for many people um
and the risk is number one if people are
deciding to just cancel a direct debit
is there could be fees if you cancel um
secondly you might be charged more if
you come off of a direct debit because
usually that's one of the cheapest ways
to pay if you build up arrears that's
another risk
and it means that being moved you can be
moved on to a pre-pay meter which also
could be more expensive so there is a
risk of being cut off there's also risk
that if you fail to pay an energy bill
it might affect your credit score but at
the same time energy companies are under
an obligation to try and find a payment
plan that might be affordable so
speaking up early and speaking to them
might allow them to review payments
reduce payments give you more time give
access to a hardship fund um advice and
also support if you're more vulnerable
as well and gemma do just remind us what
benefits have already been announced
from either the government or energy
firms in order to help people even
though we know uh clearly they're small
relative to to the price increases that
people are facing
absolutely i mean the main one was the
400 pound it started off as a as a loan
more like um but actually there's a 400
pound payment that's due in october
obviously the government's under
pressure to increase that there's also a
lot around um the warm home discount as
well so for people that for pensioners
they could get up to 300 pounds and
again that's been topped up as well to
try and help the most vulnerable but
really that isn't touching the sides
because when we saw before we saw energy
prices you know a small increase whereas
now what we're looking to face is by
january
um energy bills are set to amount to um
what people earn on average it's two
months worth of salary just on the
energy bill alone so none of none of the
benefits we've heard of so far are
really going to be able to help people
who are going to struggle to both heat
their homes and also feed their families
and wanted to get on to our next viewer
question which comes from michelle the
question being how long does it take for
fluctuating oil and gas prices to be
reflected at the pump and uh
even i guess we have seen in in the
commodity markets the price of things
like oil come off the peak does that
does that take forever to filter through
does it ever filter through
yeah it's the old rocket and feather
problem we're actually oil prices when
they go up they go up at the pump very
quickly and when they come down kind of
petrol pumps are slower to bring them
down certainly there does seem to be
some evidence of that happening i would
also say that how weak or strong the
pound is does have an effect on how much
kind of petrol at the pump does cost in
terms of gas prices and natural gas and
other energy prices that's really being
updated with the energy price cap starts
previously twice a year it'll now happen
kind of four times in a year and
unfortunately on that side of course not
any kind of good news of course we
expect that energy price cap to be over
four thousand two hundred pounds and
that's over two thousand pound increase
come january and and jeevan i mean
interestingly uh oil prices uh still
very high have come off a bit uh gas
prices have hardly pulled back much
whether we're looking at commodity
markets or uh you end user electricity
prices and the uk when it comes to
electricity predominantly gets that
through gas is that right
yeah 40 of our energy is from gas on the
40 from renewables so certainly we are
very heavily dependent upon natural gas
and natural gas prices for how we kind
of generate our own energy that's why we
one of the reasons been so exposed to
this latest increase and it's one of the
reasons why actually when it comes to
our energy production and consumption we
need to start looking at more renewables
and more ways to get to net zero you
know this isn't just about saving the
planet tomorrow it's about lower bills
today
um on to the next question which comes
from uh dan um what help is being
offered to businesses to help deal with
with rising
costs and i guess it's fair to say gemma
we we regularly talk about what is or
isn't being done to help individuals but
small businesses in particular facing
the same scale of issues
absolutely i mean this is one of the
biggest looming problems that's just not
being talked about enough because if you
think about it three out of every five
jobs in the uk is provided by a small
business um and there is no support out
there at all there's no price cap on the
energy that they pay there's no rebate
there's no payments they're going to
have and the big risk is they'll have to
pass on their higher energy costs to
consumers which means they're no longer
competitive and it means that a lot are
going to be going out of business if we
look at pubs for example a quarter of
pubs research has just shown a fear that
they could either close within 12 months
or the majority or most of them are
considering redundancies so the big
problem we talk about small businesses
but small businesses means problems with
jobs and they look there are calls to
increase the threshold for business
rates there's calls
for support to make them more energy
efficient but ultimately again in terms
of what businesses can do again going to
supplies trying to ask for help but
really there is not enough support out
there from government and um and a lot
of them at the brink because they still
haven't bounced back yet and they still
have loans to repay as well and and even
the the sort of multiplier effect um to
the downside of businesses struggling is
even worse
yeah it's one of the reasons why
expecting kind of these energy price
increases they're not just leading to
higher inflation higher prices for us as
consumers they all start to drag down on
economic production and economic
consumption as well it's less money in
families pockets to spend down at the
shop or indeed at the pub and of course
pardon themselves having to put up
prices to reflect their higher energy
cost as well it's one of the reasons
we're looking at kind of five quarters
at least a recession coming forward at
the bank of england thinks where you are
today that would be one of the most
damaging recessions in the modern
economic kind of era that's one of the
reasons why i actually do need the
government to get down energy prices yes
it does help consumers but also should
probably and hopefully help us get
through the next year and get growth
going as well um mick has the next
question for us jeevan and it's uh when
the price cap goes up what will happen
to the profits for energy companies
so for energy supplies like british gas
essential scratch the kind of energy
price cap should be reflective of the
wholesale cost if they were if the
energy price gap does reflect that kind
of properly it should lead to huge kind
of increase in profits although we have
now seen that as kind of other people
are leaving the market we are starting
to see kind of bigger profits on that
side and on the on the other side if you
like what does the energy price cap
reflect while it reflects kind of
wholesale prices for oil as well as
natural gas and as those prices are
increasing kind of those producers are
seeing huge super normal profits of
course bp and shell posting profits in
the billions and that's what at this
point in time a windfall tax to take
away some of that profit which you
should remember wasn't gained through
innovation or any kind of you know
brilliant stroke of genius on their part
but if you like a luck on those part of
those companies she has to be taxed and
put some of that money back into
households pockets and use that to
freeze energy price gap at where it is
at the moment uh of course at the same
time those companies are selling their
product globally it's not just
profiteering uh domestically and as
recently as uh 2020 we're facing the
opposite of very low prices so it does
come in and around but my question with
that in mind gemma is whether one will
ultimately hurt the prospects of the uk
economy medium to long term if you try
and hit these companies too hard in in
the short term
absolutely because again we come back to
that point that companies are employers
and they're the ones that you know we
rely on companies to to give us jobs to
help with income and things like that as
well so one of the biggest risks when we
talk about trying to avoid recession
which obviously is inevitable now is to
try and support companies to help grow
out of it and one of the biggest risks
that we face is if we don't support
we need to support households but we
also need to support companies because
you know again one of the reasons why
we're in again such a such a frantic
position when it comes to consumer
energy prices is because 30 suppliers
went bust since the start of 2021 so
there's less choice so you can't shop
around and that's just in the energy
sector so again if we don't support
companies um across the board and we're
talking about local companies that try
to remain competitive that try and help
service people's needs then you're left
with you know much larger companies that
have more monopolies and again that
pushes prices up for everybody so you
know it is a real time to kind of bounce
band together and try and help support
local businesses and just to dwell on
this point one one more juvent which is
is there a benefit to having a global
oil and gas company which clearly sells
its product the most commoditized
products by definition in the world
all around the world to have them
headquartered here
in the uk is that is there a benefit
from the the tax take for for the
exchequer
and does that have to be considered
before
crazy windfall taxes or bigger winful
taxes is what i mean are imposed
well look we do now have a global
corporation tax for a global minimum
corporation tax that should help ensure
that it doesn't matter where a company
says its operations are located it's
where they're actually located that the
tax will be levied and of course those
in the north sea they are physically
within the united kingdom's there is a
way very quickly to say actually yes
we'll be taking some of those some of
those profits some of those extra extra
cash and certainly look
at now is the right time to do so
luckily we've got agreements across the
world trying to stop profit shifting as
well so there is movement on that side
certainly you know you can't move an oil
field oil fields are where they are so
if you tax them i wouldn't worry about
them shipping that north sea oil over to
bermuda
fair enough um our next question gemma
comes from um from bayley i'm currently
a sole occupant on a pre-payment meter
should i switch to a smart meter
i mean this is a really good question
because there are lots of people at the
moment that are really struggling with
pre-payment meters because it allows
people to pay small amounts more often
but it also means that they're often
more expensive and there are fewer
tariff options another thing to consider
is the fact that there's a daily fee for
being connected that people have to pay
um even when they're out of credit and
even when they're not using electricity
but it'll be charged for them when they
start to put credit back in there and
obviously the third risk is the risk of
running out of credit and then obviously
not having any electricity at all oh and
actually the fourth one as well as the
inconvenience of having to go and top up
credit as well and i think all these
things need to be considered whereas you
know smart meters can more accurately
measure how much energy that you use um
to try and avoid overpaying but look
there's lots of considerations here and
this isn't a personal recommendation but
those are i think some general points to
consider when when trying to choose um
jeevan we end uh part one of of this
hour of uh special questions on the
cost-living crisis with a really simple
one for you which comes from a viewer
what needs to happen to fix the crisis
well look this isn't just a crisis with
basically it's catastrophe okay energy
bills are set to go up by over 2 000
pounds that's going to send middle class
families to the wall it's going to send
even more people on low income since the
destitution and to starvation it's very
clearly the first instance freeze those
energy bills where they're at now freeze
the energy price cap and use impart
windfall and wealth taxes to fund that
secondly i'd say actually also increase
public sector pay which has lagged
behind for over a decade and thirdly
increase universal and pension credits
get more money into the pockets of
low-income families you know we did not
come into this crisis in a great shape
2.6 million children are already going
hungry it's clear they need more help
but also middle-class family as well so
freeze that energy price cap and get
more money into families pockets steven
gemmer don't go anywhere we've got much
more of this cost of living special uh
to come and we'll talk about your
savings and your pensions and how much
of it is protected
next stay with us on sky news tonight
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisively
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back to sky news uh tonight in
our cost of living crisis uh special
with uh gemma and jeevan let's get
straight back into it as we said we'll
be talking about people's savings and
pensions in in this segment and uh gemma
the first question from tammy i'm due to
retire and the crisis uh has slashed my
pension how do i get by
and i think this is such a tough
question because
you know as we know pensions are one of
the most tax efficient ways to um save
for your future they're also you know
employers when employers are also
contributing as well that's free money
so it's such a shame when you know
pensions kind of get a bad rep because
obviously you know financial markets
have fallen um what's really important
to know the lessons to learn from a
situation like this is pensions should
be de-risked as people approach
retirement so you know it sounds like in
this um scenario that didn't happen
because um what should happen is is that
you know people's pensions should move
from being very much invested in the
stock market to moving to safer assets
like bonds or more cash like as you
approach the time in which you're going
to need the money um so in a situation
like this obviously losses only get
crystallized when the money actually
gets taken out and of course i don't
know the financial situation um of tammy
but you know the longer the money can be
invested the more likely it is that it
might recover in value but i also
appreciate that during cost of living
crisis that might not be an option but
you know in an ideal situation trying to
keep the money invested for as long as
possible um and reduce the amount that
you take out especially with only 25 of
it being allowed out tax-free um would
be you know maybe a sensible move
in terms of uh even
more broadly how people should be
invested right now we're asked by
another viewer uh whether inflation
that's out there is a good thing or a
bad thing for for equities for stocks
and shares
so inflation is reducing future cash
flows so unfortunately inflation is not
going to help you it looks like help
earn more money on your returns or
indeed on your stock market portfolio
and to us to a broader extent you know
the stock market should reflect i know
appreciate quantitative easing has had a
bit of a different role over the past
decade but should reflect kind of what
the earnings of companies are and that
itself should be determined by economic
growth so when you're entering very
difficult economic times you're reducing
the cash flows of companies that's also
reducing the value of your assets today
it's the real thing is actually you get
the economy greg and then hopefully kind
of get stock markets rising that would
include of course the values of pensions
and other investments as well
and that said gemma for people looking
you know the very long term if they have
to tap this money uh for a while
inflation that is out there also erodes
the value of cash
exactly i mean in a situation like this
what is guaranteed is that your money is
going to be worth less in the future
because as costs rise your money doesn't
go as far and and obviously you know
interest rates are still at the historic
lows so the rates in which you're
getting on your savings
isn't you know isn't going to give you
what you need and it's going to keep up
especially when wages aren't
outstripping inflation as well so
absolutely
for people that are younger that have
much more time to invest for at least
three to five years or longer investing
in the stock market i mean we're hearing
obviously you know the the shares of
energy energy companies that are able to
profit from higher you know the value of
energy there as well seems to be doing
quite well as well but if they have more
longer term uh to be able to invest
their money then you can ride the waves
because obviously you will see dips
along the way but being able to stay
invested for longer it is one of the few
opportunities that you get to be able to
try and beat the rising cost of living
when cash absolutely isn't eroding over
time um gemma jason asks is now the
right time to release equity on my house
i mean so this is quite a tricky one so
if we just look at the reasons why it's
a good idea and why the reasons it isn't
so obviously if you release equity or
releasing a lump sum or income in return
for some of the value of your home um
but it's quite difficult to obviously
advise in terms of you know the reason
why in the financial situation the
person but um quite we're actually
seeing a rise in people going for equity
release because with the cost of living
crisis people want to support their
children and so it has increased because
people are looking to take cash out of
their property and try and gift it to
their children who are really struggling
um so it is helpful for people that are
asset rich but cash poor
and now the products that are available
have come on quite a long way so there
are penalty-free ways to partially repay
it when you when you've obviously taken
the money out and their competitive
interest rates are still at near
historic lows um but obviously the big
challenge of this to keep in mind is you
don't get the full value of your house
you don't get the value that you would
do obviously if you're going to sell it
on the open market and obviously might
affect inheritance as well which might
be the reason you were doing it in the
first place oh just quickly on that note
even because we did see house price data
suggest a massive increase
year-over-year in the last month's data
which feels a bit odd at the moment
what are we looking at in terms of
mortgage rates and interest rates
interest rates from the bank of england
have gone up but but where do they stand
in a long-term perspective and where do
mortgage rates stand
yes so interest rates are you know kind
of beginning to rise again and actually
the market seems there's going to be
further interest rates coming interest
rate rises coming down the road so it
doesn't like actually those people who
do have mortgages if they're on a
variable rate mortgage it is going to
get more expensive and of course over
the past decade kind of interest rates
out basically around zero percent so the
kind of financing cost on that side is
going to get a lot more expensive on the
other side as well look we saw house
prices increase massively uh during the
pandemic people both had a lot of
savings at home that were sitting kind
of not doing anything they were spending
a lot less money and there was a huge
amount of kind of printing of money as
well that kind of fueled asset prices so
we saw a lot of that money being chucked
into housing it now looks like we
actually might have hit the peak of the
housing market it looks like there might
be a turn in house prices i don't want
to be too confident in asserting that
but it does seem to seem actually so
unaffordable that people can no longer
afford to get in there and that's the
cost of living right is people are more
wary kind of investing in housing as
well
and then a final one on this savings and
pension uh segment gemma can you explain
the limitations of the 83 000 pounds of
protected savings
okay um so there's good news and there's
bad news the good news is it's i think
it's 85 000 pounds there's an extra 2
000 pounds that's protected um the bad
news is the trick here is to focus on
where the money is so um what it is is
it's a compensation scheme that says
that if the institution that you invest
your you save your money with so your
bank or building society goes bust um up
to 85 000 per person her financial
institution is protected and but the
thing that the risk that people face is
that um it's per fca regulated
institution and some institutions are
actually linked so hsbc and first direct
for example are linked so watch out to
see which institution is linked because
um you can have different accounts
across different institutions and each
one will will be um
covered up to that limit but
institutions that are linked you'll only
be covered for 85 000 pounds in total
across all of those accounts gemma and
steven stay with us uh loving this uh
cost of living crisis special q and a
much more of it to come here on sku sky
news and we'll be talking about exactly
what the government is doing and what
more it could do including whether
prices will ever return to pre-covered
levels in the next segment stay with us
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back uh gemma godfrey and dr
jeevan sandor are here with me uh to
discuss the cost of living crisis we're
on to part three and talking about
government uh action and and even the
first question we've got on this topic
which more than one person sent in uh is
why the government is waiting for a new
prime minister to to come in to to take
the next steps of its action
yeah it's a great question and why did
the conservative party take a whole
summer to get here i think it took me 13
days to replace margaret thatcher in
1990 and certainly the country was not
facing the economic crises he were are
facing today uh it's completely remiss
the conservative party takes so long to
appoint a new prime minister now it is
true certainly that as things down boris
johnson doesn't have the mandate to
carry out any kind of policies that is
for his kind of
successor you know at this point in time
the cabinet wouldn't approve it and it's
not clear that actually there's kind of
a way for them to do so but actually
they need to have a new prime minister
in place and whoever that person is they
have to have a plan really ready to go
on day one but it's very remiss of the
1922 committee you know this is nothing
new we knew this was going to happen we
knew as boris johnson left that these
economic crises were coming down the way
we knew the energy price cap was going
to increase we thought there'd be a
possible summer of discontent as well we
also know that actually our relationship
with our closest trading partner hasn't
been sorted out we need someone to
actually get brexit done uh it was a
complete advocacy responsibility and
actually they should have shortened the
timetable
perhaps at the margin or albeit
different leadership rules uh for for
the re-election process done than
existed in margaret thatcher's day which
i think is is the main reason for the
the gap then either way
um gemma in terms of what people are
facing on their energy bills the next
increase while announced fairly soon
doesn't come through to october so the
new prime minister could then take
actions to reverse it if necessary in
the month of september roughly speaking
yeah i mean absolutely um and clear
decisive action is going to be needed
pretty quickly because what we've also
seen
is that the energy price cap is going to
be increased not every six months every
three months now and it's going to be
increasing again not very gradually over
those three months it's going to be
increasing very very quickly and in a
huge way as well so there absolutely has
is an opportunity to come in and do
something because again if you think
about that first payment people are
going to receive that 400 pounds that
comes in in october and there's a huge
amount of pressure either for a price
cap freeze or for that to be increased
substantially to try and help families
um because we are looking at incredibly
bleak winter and we we know that's
coming so that we know we know that
there's action that's going to be needed
and decisive very quick action as well
um steven in terms of what the action's
likely to be neil asks why is the
political focus on rebates instead of
nationalizing uh energy companies
so the main driver behind rising energy
prices at home is because global energy
prices are increasing you know the oil
price is twice as high as it was in
early 2021 natural gas is up by five
times and that's the main reason why our
bills at home are increasing and so if
you nationalize companies actually it
doesn't change the fact that global
energy prices are increasing you still
need to find a way to fund those bills
for be lower for families at home and in
part yes you can use windfall taxes and
should use them on oil and gas producers
are making huge profits but you also
need to find a way to pay down or rather
reduce bills directly for
consumers that's why we are proposing
and supporting an energy price cap
freeze that's the right thing for the
government to do there is certainly a
costed way to do so you know
nationalizing energy companies won't
necessarily lead to what you need to
have which is lower bills or consumers
at home
gemma in terms of
what the repercussions are of
nationalizations is it is it thought to
be sensible not because there is also a
point that if you look at certain
industry energies one of them trains
another one they are private but with a
lot of government support it's not like
they're purely private in the first
place
and one of the big things that obviously
we're talking about quite a lot today is
the volatility in the price as well you
know for consumers for people to budget
people usually budget annually you know
no one people aren't used to budgeting
and changing their budget so regularly
or having the ability you know people
are hard-working families can't sit down
and readjust their budgets you know
every three months so when we're talking
about um supporting energy companies
absolutely to try and help smooth that
out there's a lot of talk around that as
well um so it does obviously lend itself
to to talk about how how much more
support we can give to families and how
we can kind of link that as well but i i
think it's you know it's a very very
tough time if you think about it for
families because um you know a lot of
people have only lived in an era where
costs haven't really risen and interest
rates have been low and now they're
fighting on all fronts as well so you
know energy companies do need to provide
support as i said you know 30 suppliers
went bust since the start of 2021 so
getting more competition back in the
marketplace i'm having and again that
winful tax saying well we're going to
we're going to give you the we'll tax
you but we'll give you the money back if
you then invest it in renewable energy
or you invest in longer term more
sustainable
energy sources and solutions you know i
think more needs to be done there as
well because
like progressing our agenda towards more
energy independence and more resilient
sources is the thing that's going to be
needed um to try and stop these shocks
to consumers and families uh gemma
jonathan asks are prices uh likely to
ever come back to pre-covered levels now
the the inflation uh genie's out of the
bottle is it hard to put it back in
i mean we see fluctuations all the time
i don't want to be all doom and gloom
you know prices go up prices go down
what what it comes down to because in
this scenario everything's being driven
by higher energy prices you know food is
because of high energy prices etc so in
order to for us to see prices come down
we need to have an end to the russia
ukraine conflict as i said longer term
and energy independence more competition
back in the marketplace in terms of
suppliers and obviously this has come at
a perfect storm we were coming out of
covid as well and also brexit you know
having that adjustment as well to make
sure that we've got better supplies um
the raw material prices also come down
in terms of those issues and also we
have greater access to talent so that
wages can also be you know be controlled
as well you know all those things are
going to be needed to bring prices back
down and at the moment we're dealing
with a perfect storm in terms of a fight
on all different fronts steven i mean
the other cause for the inflation of
course uh has been loose policy whether
we talk about it through the pandemic or
for the last decade so do we also need
to see interest rates go up quite
aggressively from the bank of england or
is that counterproductive
i think we've seen the bank of england
has taken quite aggressive action send a
clear signal to the market as well as
people at home that actually they are
going to do what it takes to get control
of inflation we're also starting to see
them kind of they printed lots of money
over the past kind of during the
pandemic they're now starting to in
essence take that money back and burn it
so the bank of england now isn't like
quite an aggressive path and has sent a
clear signal about what they need all
the their kind of actions to reduce
inflation in the future i think on the
flip side now it's actually for the
government to both put money into
people's pockets as well as when it
comes to energy prices directly reduce
inflation as well um on the questions
even of uh
how much the government should be
spending to to help us regardless of
exactly how they spend it i mean where
does our national debt stand today have
they got room to borrow more uh to spend
in the short term
so certainly look how debt to gdp ratio
is about 100 which means our loan to
income ratio as a country is about one
and to put that into context like your
viewers at home when they bought houses
their loan to income ratio was three to
one now most of us as individuals
unfortunately we all die so we have to
pay down our debts to zero governments
don't face that problems the united
kingdom is very far away from any kind
of borrowing constraint if you like they
absolutely can borrow more money but the
question is what are you borrowing that
money for and is the rate of return
higher than indeed the rate of borrowing
or the cost of borrowing that you face
at this point in time first and foremost
look if you're going to fund lower
energy bills there are great ways to go
and get that money kind of tax it from
those not only windfall taxes but huge
increase in wealth that we've seen i
think 100 billion for billionaires in
this country but you're going to borrow
to invest also borrow to invest to get a
return in in many cases not just getting
to net zero but also insulating our
homes you know that's something that
kind of lowers costs for the future it
has a clear return it doesn't just
accrue to kind of every generation in
the future the next kind of 10 or 20
years in terms of lower bills but every
generation to come in terms of a planet
that doesn't burn it's a really good
case to borrow to get to net zero and
absolutely the government should be
doing that and general i guess if the
government's borrowing in the short term
and it prevents a more prolonged and
painful recession they'll in one essence
be saving themselves money down the line
this was the argument um for why during
the pandemic and the government came out
and you know
implemented furlough and was making sure
that actually people could kind of get
across and get across that that whole uh
gap in terms of their income and their
spending because the big risk was again
if people are losing their jobs they're
no longer spending a company is no
longer selling their goods companies
then lay off more people you have that
horrendous vicious circle of things
getting worse and worse and and the same
thing obviously applies in terms of
getting over um the the crisis that
we're currently facing to make sure that
people are protected but also i think
this is this is slightly this is even
more extreme because this is a
humanitarian crisis as well where people
coming towards a bleak winter people are
going to die you know people aren't
going to be able to keep themselves warm
we're already hearing stories about
people you know riding a bus to just to
try and stay warm uh when things were
cold outside so the government's under
even more pressure because again you've
got the nhs that's um that's already
quite strained um and as we approach the
winter that could get even worse so you
know this is absolutely one of these
incredibly tough times with the
government you know dipping into and
again it's our taxpayers money um but in
order to help keep the keep the country
as resilient as possible um enabling
people to get over and and stop falling
into debt is one of the most the main
priorities because actually talking
about debt the biggest
crisis there is the more people fall
into debt the more the higher the
interest payments on that debt becomes
and it becomes almost impossible for
people to then get out of it and it
becomes even more costly then to try and
save households at that point as well
steven what's the outlook of continental
europe
so concepts of europe is facing the same
kind of pressures that we are facing but
of course one thing that is also
different is the ways in which
governments are responding you know you
see about half of european countries at
the moment have some kind of price
fixing or subsidies in place we've seen
france for example almost fixed their
energy prices so in one sense concept of
europe is facing the same problems that
we're facing which is kind of wholesale
gas prices are increasing and they of
course are also receiving a lot of their
natural gas from russia
but actually the question is not kind of
what's happening the whole cell side but
what's happening on the consumer side
well we're seeing there as european
countries in particular
using their power using the government
budget to ensure that actually families
can get through this winter that is yet
to come but but uh you mentioned france
that even i mean that they've achieved
that by nationalizing edf which which
you didn't argue was what the government
should be doing here is that right
so you can't nationalize kind of energy
companies but you'll still need to find
a way to kind of pay the difference
between what's your wholesale energy
price as well as kind of what's coming
out on the other side if gas prices are
just five times higher if you were to
nationalize let's say centurica and
british gas you still need to find a way
to kind of make up the difference
between gas prices as well as lower
consumer prices and i'll say on the
french side as well edf of course a much
higher kind of nuclear energy mix there
as well so absolutely there can be cases
for it but it's not the panacea and it
certainly won't be the kind of the thing
that will get kind of immediate builds
down gemma a final question in this
section which is is very understandable
i find myself thinking it often but why
is it called a price cap if it keeps
going up
i know i always find it very funny when
we name things that absolutely do not
mean uh what will we say they do i mean
the price cap was meant to be a cap on
the also it's also a price cap on the
unit um of cost of a unit of energy as
well it's not even a cap on the total
amount that you're going to be spending
on your bills um and it is going up and
up and i think you know
during the periods where we didn't see
that much of an increase during the
periods where it would be reviewed once
every six months and potentially not
moved not changed at all you know it did
its job but absolutely right now it's
not a cap it's it's increasing and now
as i said it's shortening it from every
six months to every three months and
it's not providing consumers with um any
form of protection because the cap the
limit that we're now talking about again
for it to be too the average of a
two-month salary to pay for your energy
uh for for one month is just absolutely
um untenable and and and and people are
going to really struggle so much even as
before please stick with us we're very
much enjoying this discussion on the
cost of living crisis and uh coming up
in the final uh segment uh your
outstanding questions ranging from if
you're squeezed on private renting uh or
what to do about child care costs guy
new tonight back in a couple don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up
out and have been used as missiles to
help at these police
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now left italy and entered
france nobody's asked to check our
identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's
devastating actually
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our cost of living
crisis uh q and a uh gemma and even
still with us uh a spread of
miscellaneous questions to end uh end uh
the session with and gemma first of all
renters are getting hit hardest with no
prospect of owning a home how can we
help protect them
yeah because we keep talking about how
hard it is for people that are on
variable rate mortgages but really
renters have been hit as well so rents
are up almost 10 versus last year and
stats now show that one in five of us
are renting for up to nine years before
being able to afford our first home and
as brits we tend to okay
um but the some of the things that can
be done to try and help are you know
that of course there are schemes like
shared ownership the lifetime iso where
the government tops up a little bit up
to a certain level um but you know again
that's not really helping people whose
wages have just not kept up with rising
house prices there's also the help to
buy scheme which enables people to have
you know to afford a five percent
deposit but again you know with interest
rates going up as quickly as they are
they're also looking a little bit more
dangerous for people you know that are
going to be struggling so there's
there's things in place to protect
people from eviction there's also
obviously people that are relying on the
bank of mum and dad but most people
don't have that privilege um and that's
why again we're seeing a lot of people
moving back home to try and save up as
the only way to to get onto the property
ladder without spending the money on
rent they would otherwise use um in a
deposit uh related to that gemma aaron
asks i've signed a 12-month contract for
a spare room with bills included can the
landlord now charge for a rise in bills
i mean how enshrined are those types of
protections
and actually another challenge that
people are facing as well is that 400
pound payment that's due in october if
your landlord rather than you if your
landlord's name is on the utility bill
they get the payment and that it's up to
their goodwill as to whether they'll
pass it on so you know there are lots of
things that you know you don't really
have as much control over over your
destiny i mean in terms of advice for
this question it is about looking at the
terms of a contract because one thing to
be aware of is no landlord can charge um
you can charge for you know a higher
price than they're paying for your
utility bills um but checking the terms
to work out when they can actually
implement an increase because especially
you know it is rare to be able to do it
within a 12-month period unless it's
articulated very clearly as a term in
the contract um next one gemma the cost
of childcare is soaring and startup
starting to outstrip affordable
outgoings where can one find affordable
childcare
yeah i mean i think the the really tough
word there is affordable because again
you know the price of child care has
shot up and far more and it's
outstripped people's wages as well so
you know that is why people are seeing a
huge demand for more flexible working
cutting out commute to work work being
able to work around holidays and also
relying on family as well but a couple
of things just to focus on in terms of
government support and there's something
known as tax-free child care which is
replacing child care vouchers and again
for every eight pounds you put into your
childcare account the government puts
two pounds in up to a maximum of two
thousand pound uh per child per year and
also for three to four year olds in
addition to this you can get between 15
to 30 hours of free childcare as well
and the thing to look at is if you go to
the government website to set up a child
care account um alternatively um for
working families that qualify for
universal credit they can claim back up
to 85 of their monthly childcare costs
again up to a certain limit and those
that's the support in place but
absolutely i mean i as a working mum as
well you know i do sympathize that you
know childcare is getting more and more
expensive so you want to bring it back
to the bigger picture now as we round
off the hour and uh jeevan we've got a
hustling's going on tonight uh between
liz trust and and rishi sunak and uh
even though i know you would have liked
to see action sooner one of them will be
in place as the new prime minister by
the start of um next month what are the
top two or three things that you'd like
to see them do in order to ease this
this crisis that we've been discussing
so first of all freeze that energy price
cap you know save families over 2 000
pounds this winter that will stop
middle-class families going to the wall
the second thing is get more money into
low-income families pockets in
particular and bring back of course that
universal credit uplift that is no
longer in place you know that thousand
pounds it will help stop children going
hungry in this country as well and
finally thirdly like make sure we don't
end up in this situation again right
make sure we insulate every single home
so we lower energy prices for the future
make sure we're more dependent upon
renewables that don't mean that we are
kind of so subject to the whims of oil
and gas that are supplied by murderous
dictators the final thing i'd say is
this
both of them both rishi sunak and liz
trust are talking about tax cuts the
truth is their tax cuts will not help
families at home you know liz trusted
tax cuts like national insurance cut
only gives the average family about 110
pounds it gets a top five percent around
two thousand pounds those tax cuts will
do nothing to help families or do very
little to help families to get through
what is of course a once-in-a-lifetime
crisis general are there any relatively
simple things that haven't been done yet
that that you think would help people
well there needs to be much more
financial support for hard-working
families and i absolutely agree with the
initiatives that have been set out and i
think the only thing that i would add to
that is the importance of speaking up as
well because you know this is hitting
everybody it hits people that own a home
or a renting it hits people that have a
car and they're obviously hit by petrol
prices but also the ones that are taking
public transport to work you know so
whichever way you look at it this is
affecting people across the board and
it's so important to speak up it is
affecting people's mental health and
being able to speak to a bank to avoid
falling into an unarranged overdraft and
speaking to a mortgage provider to maybe
get a mortgage holiday and again that
could be between 1 to 12 months or
speaking to utility companies as well to
try and get a payment plan that's more
affordable you know those things could
be available and there are obviously
lots of charities as well to speak to
and i think it's very very important
that we speak up and and jeevan in terms
of the
outlook for the economy overall i mean
clearly the monetary policy is being set
by the the bank of england the
government itself can uh to oversimplify
things that think about either spending
more or taxing less and if we look at
the proposals of the two candidates one
is leaning more towards one one of those
tactics the other to the other
which actually helps the economy more at
a moment like this
spending more because those on lower
incomes will spend a high proportion of
their income you know if you do as what
liz trust wants to do give that kind of
two thousand pound tax cut the
they're going to spend or i'll save
quite a lot of that money and on the
other side of course if you give that
money to those on the lower half who are
absolutely struggling who can't even
afford to put food on the table they're
going to spend that money to go and put
food on the table and the final thing
i'd say is this an economy is not some
abstract like wild thing it is a bunch
of people or rather collection of people
that produce and consume and if people
are going hungry today it makes them
less productive at work today and if
children are going hungry today it makes
them less productive in the future so
our economy is the people fundamentally
who live in this country gemma just
finally it's been uh very downbeat i'm
not sure we can end on an optimistic
note but maybe a slightly less
pessimistic one which is you know you
said earlier recession is now inevitable
but the prospect of it being quite a
short one uh not too severe one is that
is that still within our control
well we are seeing the bank of england
be quite aggressive in terms of trying
to raise interest rates to try and
handle i mean we obviously saw a half a
percentage uh point increase and again
there's there's rumors that that's what
we're going to be seeing next time as
well so you know there is a huge amount
of focus on it there's going to be a
huge amount of pressure on the new prime
minister as well to enact and
act quickly as well and if we do so
again this is something that you know it
has been a shock but we now know what
we're facing uh we know what's needed in
terms of more support to more vulnerable
families um so it does we do have the
ability to be able to do what's needed
to try and help then grow out of it um
but yes i think it's
until that point i think with the
uncertainty people are people are you
know it's a wait and see at the moment
and people you know don't like that
uncertainty and we feel in a bit of a
power vacuum at the moment
gemma jeevan thank you both very much
for joining us on this this q a special
really enjoyed it thank you